so so you see some of this stuff that's
going on and then you see what happened
with will and uh you know with the
christmas christmas what are your
thoughts when you saw that what was your
initial reaction right i mean i think
what's
what we saw was everybody retreated to
their homes and then we went online and
you can manipulate that online we saw
that with twitter but in a stand-up show
hey just a crowd of people in my in the
microphone who's going to stop that you
know words do have a lot of power words
the words coming out of my mouth have a
lot of power that's what comedians
realize like i'm just speaking words
well
words have a lot of power so when you
have just a basic thing of me talking to
you and you're not gonna you're not
gonna censor this you know you're not
gonna censor that so stand up becomes
really powerful because like well i can
talk to this crowd here you know and
i think when when a comedian
you know we're just used to having that
kind of power and like you know we're
not used to being censored
every comedian does not like that it
just oh it's that just
grates on us you know because that's our
whole thing we need to say our words
right you know and so yeah that is your
toolbox words that are coming out of
your mouth words that are coming out of
your mouth exactly the ability to say
whatever words i want to say
so um yeah when when obviously
as a comedian to see somebody come up on
stage is terrifying to me i mean i've
had a bottle thrown at me out of the
blue but that was terrifying enough
but uh yeah it's there's there's like uh
for every comedian that's ever had that
that's a frightening thing especially
will smith he's gigantic
coming at you like uh i could see
chris's face he's like what's happening
he didn't move he just stood there like
almost
face forward like what is happening
right now no it's in surreal i mean
surreal situation you know i mean
everybody's talking about what he did
like is the guy on snl said the other
days like it feels like we've been
talking about it for five years
right well did you hear what ricky yeah
so so here's what ricky gervais said i i
don't know if it was on the view a
couple yeah it was on the timeline was
and he said the following he said i
would have uh i'll just read the whole
thing to you so he says i'll get i'll
get out of the way i have not uh i i've
got now noah will smith material i've
trended i trended when that uh trended
when that happened and i was not even
here uh what has it got to do with me
people were going what they have
anyways and then he finally says
uh well nothing as i would not have made
a joke about his wife's hair
i would have made a joke about her
boyfriend okay
what she said you know what ricky said
so yeah and by the way knowing ricky you
think ricky would have done that from
stage i actually believe he would have
done it sure i think he should look at
his golden globes
for sure yeah and by the way here's what
happened with a couple things will
smith's contract gets pulled from
academy award slap the daily caller
story netflix and sony have stepped away
from their projects with wilson a week
after he slapped chris rocket the
academy awards upcoming projects the
smith that smith expected to complete
have now officially halted as a result
of the now
infamous slap the netflix film
fast and loose and sony's highlight
highly anticipated movie bad boys four
wow bad boys four
have both been put on hold i doubt any
big studio of streamer is going to take
a chance in signing will smith until
smith's brand recovers until the process
is underway media analyst jeff bock said
you think these are the right moves
they're making i do for definitely i i
don't think there's a punishment big
enough for will smith right now you know
when i watch what he did
and it wasn't just spontaneous and
here's the a couple other things when he
was screaming at him and f-bombing him
did you see the rage in his face i mean
that was not some little throwaway line
here's the other thing will smith won
the academy award and then he had that
whole speech
about what he did right about how he's
going to be the defender of you know
people that are abused what if he hadn't
slapped chris rock was he going to use
the same speech that thing seemed very
very polished and it would have seemed a
strange
speech for someone that was playing
serena williams dad in a movie right so
i look caa had like some big time
meetings i guess over the past few days
what are they going to do one of the
founders uh brian lord wanted to get rid
of him one of the other founders who
represents him personally you know
fought to keep him and they didn't drop
him like they did harvey weinstein and
anybody else that kind of gets in
trouble in hollywood so you know i just
the more i watch this the
if you would think of one hollywood star
that would be least likely to do that
isn't that funny it's will smith or he's
one of them he just doesn't have that
reputation or at least he used to have a
reputation as being that nice guy that
non-confrontational guy apparently don't
know him as well but he deserves to
suffer some sort of career fallout for
this i'm not down for everybody just
getting canceled but usually people are
getting canceled for things that you
know they didn't have any ill will
towards they didn't do it intentionally
they just had an opinion or a belief and
people you know just decide to cancel
them but to walk on stage and steal
everybody else's night which is what he
did and slap him and it's just
unbelievable i mean and then chris rock
he's just playing it's so cool isn't he
whoever gets that first interview with
chris rock
by the way he already did his first
stand up and he says if you think i'm
going to have any will smith material
prepared to have nothing prepared he's
still thinking about it no he's gonna
sell it for sixty two hundred million
dollars to netflix well i gotta tell you
i i uh respectfully disagree with our
friend tom zenner here
this is just another example like what
did he really do he slapped another
grown man in the future oh give me a
break i know that you used to slap a lot
of men
what did i know that's your go-to move
at the oscars i don't know on stage and
slap another man in front of millions of
people all right hear me out here guy
number one before by the way tom we miss
you yeah we missed it
good good to be back before
this
you know
monstrosity of slapping someone did
anyone give two shits about the oscars
the oscars should be thanking will smith
number one and so should and so should
chris rock chris rock was career number
one i was a huge chris rock fan in the
90s
but he hasn't really done all that time
you're wrong you're wrong tom let me get
to the
let we'll get to you you've already been
offended by by will smith but this goes
to a bigger thing
and it goes to the point of cancel
culture
if we're gonna start canceling people
because we don't like what they did how
far does this go down they tried to
cancel
rogan
okay
they've been trying to cancel chappelle
we're talking about canceling comedians
and canceling entertainers
they tried to cancel bill maher people
on the left start trying to cancel bill
maher even though he's been an advocate
first thing that you said kevin was hey
we're going to talk politics i don't
want to get cancelled where the [ __ ] are
we at as a society yeah that you have to
actually worry about getting cancelled
for having opinions that's sort of the
beauty of pbd podcast we're doing
valuetainment is unless you're saying
things that are completely extreme
complete misinformation complete hate
speech say what the hell you want to say
and let the market determine what's
right and what's wrong yeah but it's
usually the people that are trying to
cancel people are fringe people who get
all worked up in a frenzy and then try
to cancel people
shout out to a good one chris farley
right there's a good one but even you
bro you've been in hollywood i mean you
you experienced this why is cancel
culture so pervasive right here but
kevin before you jump in on that weren't
you starting by defending will smith i
mean that's completely different than
some trolls on twitter i'm not defending
will smith well my my whole thing is
cancel culture here if people don't want
to go see will smith's movie don't see
his [ __ ] movie but don't say that
will smith can't work anymore what are
we talking about here no time out he
assaulted someone on stage i
shouldn't think anyone cares about that
i think i mean but you're equating chris
twitter twitter chris ross slapping a
guy
two different things chris rock didn't
press charges it sounds like you want to
press charges because you almost got not
at all i don't think i have like uh i
wanted a million opinion here point is i
want to get your thoughts on cancer
culture well now i think cancer culture
is this giant brush i mean we can be
nuanced about this
you know i mean uh we you know i think
it's like well yeah will smith can never
work again all right can we is there is
there a nuanced approach to this can we
maybe he shouldn't go to he's already
canceled from the from the academy and
he's already uh you know done his own
he's already thrown himself on the sword
in that kind of thing but what is the
oscars going to do now i think the
oscars will probably
you know
give him some kind of a punishment i
don't think that there he's not going to
get off without uh a punishment from
them
but um i think once once once all the
punishment is dealt out to him they'll
probably
he'll probably work again you know i
would imagine i suppose
we're talking about one of the greatest
performers of all time maybe not working
again
because he slaps him yeah but timeout no
one's saying that he shouldn't work
again i'm saying there should be some
repercussions for walking on stage and
slapping a man as an academy awards
as a stand-up that's so egregious
because
it's something that we all fear as we're
on stage somebody coming up either with
a gun or something like that well that's
what happens is you know when if you've
ever been on stage you're blinded by the
lights you the audience is kind of this
mob out in front of you so you have this
real visceral fear of like some somebody
coming out of the dark you know and you
know how dare you say that that kind of
thing
so uh as a stand-up i hope that he i
because i don't want this
like oh will smith got away with it and
i'm gonna do it at farley's show i don't
want that to happen so i hope that
something's deterrent there like you
know you can't come out of the stadium
you can't come out of the stands you
can't do that you know so one time one
time uh they're doing the red carpet
walk whatever it is a guy comes and
talks i don't know if you've seen this
comes and talks to
will smith and tries to kiss will yeah
and we'll slap them in the face yeah
nobody reacted to it well listen a guy
tries to kiss you in the face you don't
like that you slap him everybody says
okay cole no problem we move on mm-hmm
you know
the the part like think about it from
this standpoint
chris is a performer you're a basketball
player if you're a basketball player and
somebody walks into the floor
and does anything to you you're not a
player meaning will is not the player in
that situation will is part of the
audience in that situation it doesn't
matter like let's just say president
obama goes to a game or trump goes to a
game or you go to ufc fight yes you're a
powerful person but if you step in the
octagon and slap someone in the face
dude you can't do that that's basic
protocol the same way as conor cannot
step out and when khabib stepped out and
started chasing other people and
fighting guys you can't do that there's
certain protocols that there's
accountability the question isn't that
the question is
okay he's gonna keep his uh what do you
call it he's gonna keep his oscar fine
he resigned he can't vote anymore
whatever the the the
um
you know what he called it whatever
things that he loses right okay so
go and see other people who have been
canceled and then how long did we get
over it our conversation last night on
the drive to miami was what america is a
very
we forgive very quickly except if you
deal with kids
and if you deal with certain things so
kevin spacey is kevin going to come back
anytime soon and shoot a movie you think
he's going to do something are people
going to let that go you know it hasn't
happened yet okay it's been a couple
years i think it will do you think
america is okay if kevin did a movie and
then watch him like house of cards next
one comes out do you think people are
going to watch it i do i think i think
you think but you think people are over
that you know is it you know did he go
to jail for it are some people going to
say well innocent until proven guilty no
one's uh you know he's been accused but
he's not gone to court yet so how long
will it take the real question is how
long before people forgive him to come
back and perform i think it depends on
how much talent you have a lot of times
too well he's got a lot of time kevin
maybe one of the best actors without a
doubt you know how about ron our test
right isn't this kind of a similar
situation where they're throwing beer at
him and they go into the stands he at
least was punished for a little while he
couldn't play in the nba that's all i'm
saying about will smith we don't have to
cancel him but hopefully he can learn
from this and there are there's some
sort of punishment that comes from this
by the way why does chris farley decide
or i mean chris rock decide if presses
or if charges are going to be pressed
isn't that usually i know this happens a
lot but you would think the police see a
crime in their mind being committed they
just arrest somebody it seems strange
when you have to go to the victim and
say do you want to press charges
also yeah i agree i mean it should be
the cops probably do that i mean that's
what happens in the domestic batteries i
think that no matter if the wife
sometimes says no don't don't touch them
i think the cops still
arrest the guy but i think that um also
this has to do with these sexual crimes
you know like if you look at the three
guys that are um
banned from the oscars harvey weinstein
and uh
roman polanski and then um who's the
third guy i don't know well there's a
guy nice to giffen but he's not yet
right but they're all sexual crimes yeah
so that's that's something to do i don't
think we forgive the sexual stuff i
don't think we do no i don't think
harvey's ever going to be forgiven
that's why i'm saying kevin
is in the middle of maybe never being
forgiven some people would say never but
will what he did you know how long six
months yeah twelve months i think kind
of sometimes
by the way speaking of sexual crimes you
see who's getting a lot of heat right
now is jim carrey we've seen what
happened with him on cbs when he no well
he came out and he basically was like if
i was chris
i would file this ridiculous lawsuit and
and basically defending chris rock
defending comedy and someone goes oh you
know the beautiful thing about the
internet jim carrey
uh the [ __ ] doesn't go away so fast
forward or reverse to a clip of him when
i mean
after your brother passed away arguably
jim carrey took the mantle of the most
outlandish over-the-top comedian i mean
fair point
um
he wins the award i think it was
comedian of the year whatever it was mtv
award yeah and the presenter of the
award was none other than clueless star
alicia silverstone oh yeah um
silverstein silverstein
um
he wins the award and please
give it up for jim carrey comes on stage
grabs her two hands in the face boom
lays a huge kiss right on her face and
holds right yeah good five second kiss
she's shocked yeah the whole crowd is in
an upward keep in mind he is
the performer of performers of that time
this is probably 2 000 ish i don't know
if you want to pull this up but now
basically
you know people are like oh jim carrey
you have an opinion well let's research
roll the clip
boom i don't know and now he's kind of
catching backlash camp so it's almost
like you can show up if you speak out
and have an opinion they're gonna oh
yeah they're gonna double back to
something you did 20 years ago sure and
they're going to try to cancel you now
jim carrey so it's a very thin line that
you have to balance right now yeah it is
what does that tell you though what does
that tell you i don't i mean that tells
you you know before you're going gonna
judge just kick back a little bit and
you know
uh uh
if you've walked on water go ahead and
judge all you want if you haven't you
know
so i again i think america is very
forgiving i think america moves on from
certain things this being one of them
it's just a matter of how long if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]